[Music]
in Colt Network News submitted by Edgar
from Australia hello Ike well the Church
of Scientology has just launched their
own TV network I am gonna watch that
that's just be hilarious I would
actually watch it sounds kind of boring
it might be like pretty cool sci-fi [ __ ]
because they believe in like aliens and
volcanoes exploding and spirits coming
out or some [ __ ] have you been to the
psychology center psychiatry the the
history of like abuse or whatever it's
like gone Hollywood Boulevard I think is
it the Celebrity Center no no it's a
different one it's actually the big blue
building it's a big propaganda museum
like anti-psychiatry I met a person who
grew up in the church what that's time
and they like she's awesome she's cool
but she's not a part of it anymore and
her family's not a part of it anymore
one of my favorite things to do is to
listen to podcasts from people from
North Korea and people who survived
Scientology those things to me simpler
insane she was telling me that it's like
complete brainwashing or there's a
difference between like regular goers of
Scientology and then there's this
exclusive club called like the the C
Club or something like that and once you
get into this group then you're
completely inside like you give them
everything like they put you in debt
somehow you work for them like 24/7 but
if you're just a regular person just
going to the Scientology Church it's
like a college you just sign up for
classes and then you get these different
levels but she says after a while her
mom was like burning so much money and
she was like wait so this is all that
happens after you pay this much money
and then they left and probably lose a
lot of their members yeah nothing
happened have you heard all his Leah
Remini stuff man
oh yeah he is so good dude on like all
this Scientology stuff talking about how
when she got to the highest level or
whatever when she was like clear or
whatever the [ __ ] you call it she was
told that like the volcanic planet or
whatever is controlling the world [ __ ]
just like whatever crazy [ __ ] right well
the zine of Xenu yeah you know just
crazy stuff like it's like good acid
trip like like it's basically what l ron
Hubbard wrote all the time he just wrote
another book and called the Scientology
well it's just sci-fi like novel you
have to
yeah trashy sci-fi novels - like not
good stuff he wasn't known as a good
author like it was like pretty pretty
good scam artist though now Scientology
has a whole TV network so I'm gonna show
you guys a clip noting this network
makes me wanna join the call whoa
yeah that looks fun now they're gonna
get so many followers
damos dope what was that
what's that room all about
[Applause]
it looks like a DeVry University c'mon
oh my god no out really I want to be a
Scientologist too Coulter far already
yeah oh my god it's not someone's dick
or something if you suck dick yeah
that's a lot with TV that's all good
Android firestick Roku another crazy
thing is what she told me is she has
family members that are still part of
like the deep deep Scientology and you
had you get excommunicated yeah she's
cut off right they can't even talk to
her yeah her family is just they can't
talk to her own family members Wow like
if you leave the church that's it so a
lot of people are afraid to leave
because you start from rock bottom in
the regular world I don't know man I
don't know if I believe it because that
video looks so [ __ ] fun that's true
like I don't know if that why would you
be afraid to leave that right I mean
that is like a vacation so you're going
to sandals the Rye University commercial
where they're trying to make it fun for
me to learn
[ __ ] that [ __ ] are you trying to learn
[ __ ] with a yacht anything will be dope
if North Korea had an advertisement like
that
do-do-do-do-do-do-do North Korea and
then there's like [ __ ] boats yeah
like bawling and then there's like a
person like pointing fingers yeah yeah I
mean having simi's but I heard that the
ISIS recruitment videos are like this
too or they try to make it seem all fun
and [ __ ] dude their base that music on
every racist recruitment videos are very
fun that's everything they look at the
army recruitment videos like they make
it seem so bad and then you're like
hanging down a pair of shooting and
cheering you're not doing that you're
cleaning a toilet they [ __ ] up dude a
military video where it's just like a
dude sitting on a couch eating some
pizza yeah you're into that right you're
speaking right to me
that's what they should do motivational
music to the most mundane yeah yeah
remember high school our world was an
elementary school of magazine sales oh
yeah yeah with where the guy would come
out and like start handing kids $1 bills
and they're all like what are we getting
so much money like you're literally just
it's a pyramid scheme thing we're like
what do you call it multi-level
marketing where it's like you go and
sell ten magazines to your relatives and
then they pay you and then I get we get
most of the cut and then you get to go
on up stupid
vacation to somewhere local I usually do
those mail-order ones when they when
these random things come into your mail
and you're like I want these magazines
and then they just keep sending it to
you
you're the sucker who does that you pay
for it my parents probably did oh man I
probably just got their credit card and
wrote it all down they would play one of
these videos and then they would have a
kid one kid got picked and the kid would
stand like a booth right and they would
close the booth and they would fill it
with with air and all this money starts
shooting up in the air and he has like
eight seconds or something to grab all
the money you can and then they would
take all the money out and then they
would count it out in front of all of us
and every time that he put it in his
hand it would go cut ching cut ching and
like by the end of it it's like he made
22 dollars and we're like like that's
the kind of propaganda at North Korean
all these guys should do cuz we love it
and then I wanted to sell I was like
gonna be the Bill Gates of magazine
sales for like three hours after that
thing and then wears off oh it always
wears off yeah your motivation it's like
when I did the big help for Nickelodeon
remember that we all did done right
Nickelodeon's like how many how was you
gonna pledge and every time that you
called you've got to hear a different
character from Nickelodeon and so I
would just call it like by the end of
the thing I owed like thirteen thousand
hours or something and I went outside
for thirty minutes my friends we started
cleaning up trash and we're like this
sucks I remember they used to have this
like Jewish telethon during
Christmastime and there would be all
these like old Jewish guys dancing in a
circle and until like call now support
and I remember being a little kid
watching that [ __ ] and I called
would they say I don't remember I just
call the number and I was just listening
and I hung up yeah so this whole
Scientology Network thing they're
breaking it down each show that they're
gonna have so it's like inside
Scientology is pretty much I can extend
it infomercial of the church with pretty
much what we just saw that's inside
Scientology and then there's other show
called voices for Humanity where it's
like a documentary-style show where it
focuses on the church's volunteer work
and this other show called meet a
Scientologist where they're interviewing
real-life Scientologists the [ __ ] wants
to meet just well right you could do
that in like Pasadena or wherever they
are there's they're like read yeah you
could get like a free reading and
they're guaranteed gonna tell you how
[ __ ] up you are like I I bet you there
there's never a moment where they're
like oh [ __ ] you know what you're
actually a pretty decent balance too and
maybe you don't need this well the
science behind is so good to this little
machine that feels your energy or some
[ __ ] high tech spiritual like do that
and just have them come into like your
well yeah I was like I disagree yeah the
same show which is just bring our own
[ __ ] right as I watch this I met
those people though like you've ever
cross paths with those people where
they're like how are you feeling today
and you're like actually pretty good no
really I know man like come on no but
how are you really yeah you're like no I
am pretty good like really I feel pretty
[ __ ] not everyone is as this depressed
as you are you [ __ ] dig and they dig
and they dig and then you're and then
you're just like [ __ ] I don't have that
if they keep asking it's just like how
do you feel now [ __ ] angry yeah I did
not want to kick your ass
yeah now get the [ __ ] away from me
before you die but that must stem from
your your upper low it stems from the
[ __ ] face I'm about to pound in I
like the aggressions definitely coming
okay fine fine I sucked my dad's dick
like what do you want
you see we should talk about this
they broke you these [ __ ] people are
good they're awesome you should just do
it the other way like yeah I'm kind of
sad I only made a million dollars last
year and I'm kind of sad because all my
family members are healthy and they're
really nice to me
yeah but Scientology they here you got
money me like yeah now they're not gonna
leave you alone how are you really
feeling well kind of murder my mom
yesterday generally turn out to ones
though mmm like I think about my mom
naked in the shower is that weird guess
I never thought about this before you
got it you got a minute
hey if you do that [ __ ] I'd be fine Oh
imagine if you were totally desperate
and then you [ __ ] annoyed the [ __ ]
out of average I like forget it you're
going to hell that's what I would do the
door-to-door guys yeah oh that was fun
man oh did your hobo witnesses don't
even come to my house anymore cuz my
dad's like a minister right and like he
went through like the whole Christian
theology thing he had like a mass
everything so they would come over my
dad's like come inside let's talk they
never came back cuz my dad literally
talked their ears off for like three
hours yeah yeah it was like literally in
the backyard and they just never came
back again you'll be there for I [ __ ]
3-4 hours my mom's like making them food
[ __ ] that's the one situation where I
wish that I had like like I like a
[ __ ] pipe or something so I'm like
yeah come on in I'm like you guys more
anything like I wanna smoke a price
taker what's up like all that kind of
doing a line put porn on like you know
have it all ready to go you should hire
strippers every day just just in case
they come over and in just oh you guys
are here just in time this is why when I
am rich man I'm gonna do such fun stuff
oh man now you're the second person I
hope gets thank you he was the first
night of the second yeah we're gonna
watch hunter for all of it yeah
absolutely
I'll have a lot of fun toys and
activities and he will troll the world
why why he's not gonna have fun though
cuz well Jessa's in his life and you
no more millions for you ah you can
still have them yeah thank you
you had my number one oh thank you well
yeah I will do I will II will do fun
stuff you'll see I feel that I feel like
you're gonna give me your money
if I it's like me and him are competing
for the money it's like well if I win
should I have the opportunity if I give
her what she wants I I could go as crazy
as I want
did you give Jess what you want so
responsive yeah I don't see it happening
for you it's gonna wear like how the two
white people in the group are the most
Asian out of all of us so truly
disappointed if she [ __ ] matches you
buddy
[Music]